jede minute zählt
im raum mailand ambulant sirenen zu
jeder tageszeit
das epizentrum der korona epidemie in
europa die lombardei eine notruf
einsatzzentrale im norden von mailand
das team macht sich für einen corona
einsatzbereit alltag für die
rettungsleute jeden tag neue
schutzbekleidung das virus ist aggressiv
oberstes gebot sich nicht anstecken
steige mit hoffnung in den tag dass es
bald aufhört seid ihr müde
[Musik]
wir denken an unsere familien und hoffen
dass wir jeden tag wieder gesund nach
hause kommen
täglich sind wir mit personen in kontakt
die leider am virus erkrankt sind
dieser fronteinsatz vermerk nicht so
sehr körperlich einem seele
im inneren der einsatzzentrale die
telefone laufen sturm fast alles corona
anrufe direktor rossano kg sie ist wie
alle im dauereinsatz
er weiß was es für patienten bedeutet
wenn die ambulanzen vorfahren lassen
dass sie in eine spezialabteilung eines
spitals kommen werden falls die korona
diagnose bestätigt wird
dort werden sie komplett alleine ohne
kontakt zu angehörigen das personal in
den spitälern macht alles um ihnen zu
helfen
aber leider sind alle am anschlag die
patientenzahlen steigen
die spitäler stehen vor dem kollaps das
team ist startklar
ein neuer tag im kampf gegen bochum
[Musik]
im minutentakt fahren bei den
notaufnahmen der lombardei die
ambulanzen vor
die spitäler nehmen rund um die uhr neue
patienten auf
die zahl steigt in italien jeden tag
ungebremst an
die lage ist dramatisch täglich tausende
neuerkrankungen
fast 3500 personen liegen in
intensivstationen und kämpfen um ihr
leben in den umgerüsteten cupid
abteilungen das zischende geräusch der
beatmungsgeräte
[Musik]
die schwer erkrankten müssen künstlich
beatmet werden
das virus greift die lungen an ohne
beatmung würden die patienten ersticken
vor allem betagte menschen kämpfen um
ihr leben
hier zeigt sich das drama in seiner
vollen härte
kommt dazu in der lombardei gibt es
trotz ausbau nicht genug intensiv plätze
es fehlt an betten und personal
wir sprechen mit francesco blasi
leitender arzt der intensivstation der
universitätsklinik von mailand täglich
steht ihr vor schweren entscheidungen
wir müssen von fall zu fall entscheiden
es gibt patienten die wenig chancen
haben die krankheit zu übergeben
die anzahl betten ist limitiert so sind
wir gezwungen auszuwählen drehen wir
helfen es geht manchmal nicht anders
ideal wäre es allen zu helfen
unmöglich beim coruna virus für viele
patienten kommt jede hilfe zu spät
die therapien gegen das virus sind sehr
belastend das spitalpersonal ist seit
wochen am anschlag
jeder zehnte hat sich angesteckt 29
ärzte sind in italien bereits gestorben
viele gehen gar nicht mehr nach hause
das schlimmste ist so viel leid zu sehen
so viele viele menschen die leiden und
alleine sind und du kannst eigentlich
nur sehr wenig tun
du bist einfach da
[Musik]
ich bin zwei stunden täglich am telefon
mit angehörigen von schwerkranken sie
dürfen ja nicht ins spital kommen trotz
sorgen und leid sagen alle im am ende
gute arbeit halten sie durch das berührt
mich immer wieder leichen in einem
spital zimmer täglich sterben in italien
hunderte personen am corona virus bis
heute über 6.800 tote es ist wie im
krieg ein großes problem wir versuchen
vor allem den angehörigen nahe zu stehen
dieser fahrer wurde vor zwei wochen von
einem italienischen fernsehteam in einem
spital von bergamo gefilmt seit wenigen
tagen ist er in quarantäne
er hat sich angesteckt seit ausbruch der
epidemie sind allein in bergamo 13
priester gestorben
in den friedhöfen der lombardei
bestattungen im minuten takt vor dem
friedhof von bergamo stehen die
leichenwagen schlange angehörige sind
nicht zugelassen
die familien dürfen nicht dabei sein
die region lombardei hat es verboten wir
fahren die toten an dem friedhof und
fertig bergamo ist mit der anzahl der
opfer überfordert das zeigen diese
bilder vergangene woche transportieren
armee lastwagen dutzende särge in andere
krematorien norditalien
[Musik]
das corona virus hat italien extrem hart
getroffen wie konnte es dazu kommen
wir treffen die virenexperten m a hot
croft im biozentrum der universität
basel hat die epidemiologin ein programm
entwickelt das die ausbreitung der
korona epidemie visualisiert wir sehen
dass es in italien mehrere brennpunkte
gleichzeitig gab mindestens zwei
möglicherweise mehr
es war darum sehr schwierig in italien
diese epidemie zu verhindern
bei einem brennpunkt hätte man die
ausbreitung rechtzeitig stoppen können
aber weil es mehrere gleichzeitig gab
war das in italien nicht möglich alfons
labisch ist eine der bedeutendsten
experten für medizingeschichte und lehrt
heute an einer universität in peking
warum hat italien heute mehr corona tote
als china vermutlich schwer erkrankt
sind
die coruna virus katastrophe
das beispiel italien als warnung an alle
großbritannien stand heute laut whu rund
6700 infizierte 335 tote
das land hat dichtgemacht anfänglich
hatte premierminister boris johnson noch
von herdenimmunität gesprochen das heißt
ein hoher prozentsatz seiner population
wird immun durch ansteckung oder impfung
jetzt aber der aufruf bleibt zu hause
ich bin sehr froh zu sehen dass sich
großbritannien von der herdenimmunität
strategie abgewandt hat wir erwarten
dass italien bald die herdenimmunität
erreicht das wird ihrer epidemie helfen
aber schauen sie sich die folgen kann
herdenimmunität ist keine bagatelle
es bedeutet dass ein sehr großer teil
der bevölkerung infiziert sein muss für
die alten kann das verheerende folgen
haben
usa stand heute
rund 42.000 infizierte 470 tote
besonders hart getroffen ist der staat
new york
in vielen staaten werden personen
getestet
trotzdem propagiert präsident donald
trump bereits die rückkehr zur
normalität
journalisten die ihn dafür kritisieren
greift ihr rüde an
das ist ein sehr schlechtes signal dass
sie dem us volk geben
die amerikaner wollen antworten und
hoffnung sie suchen nur sensationen
angesichts steigender infizierten zahlen
könnte trumps haltung fatale folgen in
der krise haben
ich denke dass sich die dinge weltweit
noch eine weile verschlechtern werden
besonders in europa und den usa stehen
wir vor einer zunahme der fallzahlen
dies ist ein exponentiell wachsen des
virus die anzahl der fälle verdoppelt
oder verdreifacht sich jeden tag
es beginnt mit kleinen zahlen und wächst
plötzlich rasant zum herkunftsland des
corona virus nach china region who bay
statt
hier wurde die epidemie unterdessen
gestoppt das resultat von zwei monaten
truck komischer maßnahmen von den
behörden mit aller härte durchgesetzt
[Musik]
china war sehr drastisch sie haben
gezeigt dass wir aus kann eingedämmt
werden
in den meisten ländern könnten solche
maßnahmen nicht umgesetzt werden zurück
nach mailand in die lombardei
zurück in die rote zone daniele und
dajana vom misericordia team sind wir
heute bereits beim sechsten chor ohne
einsatz für viele hier sind sie helden
ich sehe mich nicht als heldin
ich versuche in diesem drama einfach nur
mein bestes zu geben und zu helfen
in der ambulanz einsatzzentrale warten
unterdessen andere teams auf ihren
einsatz
direktor parisi brief seine leute hier
in bergamo seit in die gefährlichsten
zone also höchste sicherheitsstufe
auch in mailand hat sich die situation
verschlechtert also passt auf leute wie
immer kraft und mut immer weiter und
schützt gute arbeit
unter den rettungsleute steigt die sorge
um mailand dass es auch hier zum
desaster von bergamo kommen könnte wir
kämpfen jetzt um mailand
die zahl der ansteckungen steigt rasant
und unsere einsätze auf ja es ist eine
schlacht
es sei wie im krieg sagen die
rettungsleute immer wieder
viele ambulanzfahrer rettungsleute und
sanitäterinnen gibt es im drama immer
wieder auch bewegende momente da war ein
alter mann der leiter von einem corona
team abgeholt und ins spital gefahren
werden musste als sich der patient im
innern der ambulanz befand standen seine
angehörigen draußen um sich zu
verabschieden
der betagte mann weinte winkte mit der
hand da warf ihn seine enkelin eine
blume
das war auch für uns ein starkes zeichen
ein zeichen der hoffnung
italiens kampf ist wichtig für ganz
europa von den erfahrungen werden viele
länder profitieren auch die schweiz
findet professor blasi es gibt maßnahmen
die sofort getroffen werden müssen
wir haben vielleicht etwas spät reagiert
um das hat uns dann in schwierigkeiten
gebracht
ich glaube die schweiz ist gut
aufgestellt und erfolgen zu begrenzen
das ist das wichtigste vorbereitet sein
denn die welle wird kommen auch heute
starben in italien hunderte am corona
virus ein ende dieser tragödie ist nicht
in sicht
[Musik]